dude there's no difference between six
figures any figures like what's the
[ __ ] difference
like I get I understand like practical I
understand but like what two extra
bedrooms yeah
yeah what's up blog good day little
gloomy here about to have a great
meeting with Kailen Kailen five years
whose real veteran love you uh
everybody's doing well thank you so much
for anybody who's listening to the
airport project have you listened to the
project happen see do you see how scared
she got cuz she's about to ask her a
very detailed question good seven uh see
ya should be a good day lot going on
hope to see all of you later got some
stuff we've got four news today's that
should have some stuff so she never post
selfie in a while I see it I like it one
day if you had a sweet you get me
invited and be excited and be about it
and put you not disturb I don't up
hallways here with skin life is good if
you're good enough it always pays off
that's the biggest thing everybody's
confused about it with patience the
reason patience is the best strategy is
because the merit of your skills will
play out in the long term will it work
out I don't know how talented you are my
intuition is you're hungry is [ __ ] and
so that already you know to me it's
patience ambition and talent so you've
got ambition
everybody's got ambition or let me
freeze a lot of people have ambition a
lot of people actually have talent
especially if they're self-aware with
their ambition and talent then they can
really win nobody has patience hell yeah
slap yeah apps to get here in are your
problems and how they play let me state
the truth but your boy stop and see
yourself Amer I'll take nothing serious
that even this millennium blanco heading
into a client feeding the one seven
figures y'all successful meeting client
this is Marcus Cruz a sec what's going
on airplane project still in fact how
you doing that's good man it makes me
happy
one thing with him that's different is
the youngsters [ __ ] with him on a
respect level that's different that's
why I'm gonna win
it's not how cool or big I'm gonna be
seventeen million Instagram followers in
four years is gonna be great it'll be
cool but it's not gonna make people like
I'm not gonna be able to move America to
all of a sudden by myself give a [ __ ]
about whatever the [ __ ] I deploy that
against the thing you have is the
tentacles as an entrepreneur and
business man within people that are
moving culture it doesn't matter what
the migos are doing it matters who the
me goes look up to that's where scale
comes in in but [ __ ] man I think
Atlanta's culture and I think you need
to be super thoughtful about how much
leverage that actually is I think you
guys take it for granted because that
you know it just feels normal
you're so in it it feels normal you take
it for granted like I just think it's
[ __ ] really matters like at a level
that [ __ ] confuses me meaning like
just watching it go from you know la
Reed and now get like just watching it
my whole life like the leverage is so
real the thing the thing that [ __ ] with
me the most is the difference between 21
savage rust amigos like Danny Glover
like the Hollywood [ __ ] that's happening
in the [ __ ] the suburbs like there's
so much really happening
that's what I'm good I'm good at
people's attention hmm that's why I
invested in Facebook and Twitter and
uber before everybody else I knew it was
gonna happen I really think you guys can
build some big-ass businesses it was a
pleasure to play this event that's me my
man but it work you they don't warn you
things are when I put up the five don't
shake my [ __ ] hand
a mattress it was so did you get my look
in the camera cuz he grabbed my hand do
you know this mean did you capture it I
think I think we got it I think you got
it I think it's gonna be a meme and a
half I did the five he put the grip he
shook it and I looked at the camera
which is gonna be amazing you mind
signing it yes we got it 100% what's his
name he actually brought five coffees
that's amazing can you put my name in
and I was like I I might be able to
possibly there's a lot of great reasons
to build a personal brand both like on a
selfish human level and on a business
level but the way to build the best and
biggest personal brand is to not
monetize the audience one of the ways I
figured out how to do that was to get
book deals and speaking engagements
where I wasn't monetizing the audience
the key is a couple things first and
foremost for everybody here and this is
like giving advice that will transcend
for everybody there's three ways humans
communicate the written word audio and
video you should do them all if you can
afford to and if you cannot my big thing
is to become self-aware of how you best
communicate it would be a real mitzvah
using a nice Jewish word on Hanukkah if
you could do video because video can
give you the other two and the way you
do that is the way I do it it's video
because you guys know if you listen to
my podcast it becomes audio pretty
easily and you can literally hire an
intern or get somebody to work for free
based on the successes you've had to
transcribe it into written and now
you're reaching people everywhere now
you have a blog and a medium and a
LinkedIn presence now you have a YouTube
and a facebook video presence now you
have a podcast presence my part of this
equation to make you win is to try to
get you not to monetize them for as long
as possible if ever dude there's no
difference between six figures and eight
figures like what
the [ __ ] difference like I get I
understand like practical I understand
but like what two extra bedrooms like
what an extra trip like the caviar
supplement like like what right like the
reason to make more money is to close a
vulnerability and an insecurity the
reason young men want to make money is
to get girls and that's and that's the
point I really mean that I mean you
literally like have no like there's not
a whole lot especially we give any [ __ ]
about legacy people say they want legacy
but they use that as the skies to make
more money tell your story in a [ __ ]
minute and then you have to understand
why this is important because tomorrow
Instagram announces that videos are now
not capped at one minute and we're all
like oh like everybody makes decisions
based on the rules of today when these
platforms change the rules on an
everyday basis so first figuring out it
was a lot easier to convert people with
the word wine then it was 1997 Super
Tuscans right it's I get it it's easier
for you to fully articulate your whole
goddamn thing in 3 minutes and 19
seconds go challenge yourselves for once
because this is all becoming variant
like you guys have it cool alright I
gotta go
[Music]